well for the very latest now let's cross
over to Harare where our correspondent
Adrian Creech is standing by Adrian the
results came in in the middle of the
night what's been the reaction so far
this morning well the situation here an
hour is still a little bit tense I would
say knife is not fully back to normal it
has improved compared to yesterday for
example when you could only see police
and military on the streets today you
still see police and military on the
streets but some of the shops have
opened some banks even opened so it's
slowly getting back to normal but some
people you have the feeling that the
whole election drama is not yet over and
we will talk about the reasons right now
we have two guests here one
representative of the opposition party
mr. Jameson timba he is the chief
election agent for mr. Tomita the
presidential candidate of the opposition
party and we also have a representative
of the zanu-pf the governing party in
Nick Morgana
he's the zanu-pf representative in
Europe I would like to ask you first mr.
timbre you party is not accepting the
results of these elections why they are
a lot of discrepancies in this natural
process but in terms of procedure and
process in the manage what was done and
our position is very clear we have not
accepted the outcome of this election
and they say what's your reaction to
that well it's no surprise these guys
have been fearing these elections for a
very long time they even say that the
only result I would accept is the one in
which they would ever bid will come out
victorious now this is a result in which
they were loved in a big way so they
will not accept that's not a surprise in
from where we stand as an OPF you engage
in a process you have endured the
process when in does a process induce an
outcome that's opposition now what's
your way forward and if you will not
accept the results are you gonna
challenge them court or are you calling
for demonstrations first of all we do
not endorse an election 1610 of the
Electoral Act requires that the Zek must
put before the election a sense of all
the presidential candidates the v23 form
which shows the presidential result
per constituency
it is that v23 which must be verified by
each of the audience who then sign of
that result before it is announced they
indicated to us that before we do any
announcement we shall call you back show
you the result in terms of the v23 okay
verify that and then announce and it
didn't happen so but what's the way
forward then what's with this year plan
we will be indicating to you our plans
but I can tell you that we are not
accepting this result and we are not
accepting this outcome so are you going
to court well we are going to be
challenging this as out but I'm not
going to come out lately but at this
juncture to tell you how we've seen an
outbreak of violence on wednesday in
particular when opposition demonstrators
went to the streets to protest and the
security forces apparently killed six
people the government is in charge of
the security forces why did that happen
I don't speak for the government
I speak was an opf but that said they
didn't go to the streets to protest they
went to the streets to vandalize
property they went to the streets to
cause mayhem they burned his own opf bus
they tried to burn Sunapee of
headquarters they provincial
headquarters they tried to invade the
sunapee of headquarters out there to end
and and I couldn't be allowed to do that
they tried to come in here they smashed
that up that post today as you can see
it's war smashed up so you cannot say
that it was just a protest no it was
vandalism that side it's unfortunate and
very sad that people lost their lives
and it shouldn't be mr. timbre set is
not sure if there will be demonstration
on what's the way forward is we can
still see massive security force
presence here will demonstrations be
allowed I don't speak for government at
all speak for the security organs either
but demonstrations are normal allowed in
Zimbabwe
what's not allowed is people trying to
smash up things people burning buses
people burning cars people having petrol
bombs people my routing around the
street with my sheets no that's not
allowed so he's saying basically the
members of your party
staged that violent protests is that
true enough that is not correct what
happened two days ago was a spontaneous
reaction to the rigging and theft that
is been taking place when as far as
these elections we'll say it was a
spontaneous response by ordinary people
have been suffering with +30 80s Alison
90% of our youth today are unemployed
and all they need is a very small
trigger and that's what happened what we
are living under now is a police state
it is a military state in which people's
freedoms are contained you cannot have
an army opening live amination against
an unarmed defenseless population it can
never be justified under any
circumstances a last quick question to
you he's mentioned 90 percent
unemployment zanu-pf has run down the
economy of this country heavily indepted
zimbabwe is a lot of people say there's
no way out of that what will the new
presidents do to get the country back on
track the new president is already
getting the new today the country back
on track with 70,000 people employed in
in a period of six months but yes there
has been a lot of things done we have
couldn't account for
President Mugabe but there is a lot of
things these guys have to account for
the assumptions that this country has
been under which still under they are
the ones they damage advocates for them
the MDC the MDC the party represents
they are still advocating for those
these moves this manages to put the
country in a crisis mode is again to
suppose to put or to bring it back to
visit rather it's suffering upon the
people of Zimbabwe so that they would
protest against the government and then
their protest will be there of what they
have no program their program is a
protest thank you very much gentlemen
and we go back to terry with that Thank
You Adrian thank you so much for
rounding that up and thanks also to your
two guests a to increase their in Harare